this is a production of Cornell
University well I want to thank Adrian
for a very generous introduction
probably over generous and I want to
thank you for coming to hear this talk
which may never be given okay so I chose
modeling as a topic for my presentation
because it appears to be particularly
relevant and very timely
well I can I can share a little bit of
personal history I was looking up in my
diary actually in my journal and I found
out that within two days in 1978 I
actually gave my entrance seminar to the
department in this room so the choice of
gate seems particularly apropos the
difference of course was that the
seating arrangement was completely
reversed the screen was in the back all
the chairs faced that way and instead of
having a computer with powerpoints that
don't work there was a there was a two
by two slide projector which did work
yes so a botanist a zoologist in a
mycologist walking into a bar okay I'm
not gonna touch anything I'm just gonna
touch the clicker okay okay now I'm
actually going to turn off the lights
because I'm a morphologist and I'm used
to working in the dark okay so the
reason I picked the topic is because it
appears that modeling has taken a new
high road recently this is actually a
quote from a 2016 NSF report talking
about the importance of biological
modeling and the fear that it might
actually fall between the cracks of
funding agencies so certainly NSF and a
number of other funding agencies have
taken note that biological modeling is
important and no higher authority than
Wikipedia actually actually has an enter
the entrance talking about biological
modeling and the systems to a variety of
biological disciplines so I think
talking about modeling in general is
particularly interesting and relevant
but I will tell you when I was a
graduate student and I started doing my
first modeling it was actually frowned
upon it was thought to be mostly you
know smoke and mirrors most people
really didn't trust mathematics or at
least not mathematics applied to
biological systems the only point of
entry in the old days was really in
ecology where a lot of ecological
modeling had become fashionable so what
am I talking about when I actually am
using the word modeling so I went to
Webster's dictionary and of course
looked up the various definitions for
model you know representation of a
person a thing or a phenomenon or a
system that can be used as an example so
a model person a model system me maybe a
rabid OPS's most certainly but the kind
of definition that I want to use is a
material visual mathematical or
computational analog used to construct a
theory now notice to construct a theory
and notice the entrance says see also
hypothesis or theory and that's what I
mean by modeling at least in the context
of my talk now what drew me to look into
modeling is that ever since I started
studying biological systems I've always
really been fascinating
by the relationship between organic
structure and function and I've been
interested in that for a very long time
even actually as an undergraduate major
in mathematics because you can't help it
look at a plant or an animal and think
about its structure and its function
that could be quantified using the tools
of math and physics there's another
dimension however and that is my
background in PhD thesis had to do with
evolution and so the other axis in this
interest is how the environment
influences the interplay between organic
structure and function and the
historical aspects that have led up to
the structure function relationship so
this actually is an interplay of at
least four very important components
that converge on our understanding of
what a plant a fungus or even a
bacterium is so when you start looking
at the application of the physical
sciences towards biology being a
physical scientist it's actually
comparatively easy I made a little list
here if you're an engineer or a
physicist of what you have to look
forward to if you're designing a
structure and mechanism of some sort you
know where that mechanism is going to
function the workplace is already
specified for you and the design
specifications are specified for you how
big is the machine of big is the
structure that you're doing and the
function of that structure is already
specified a priori so an engineer is
given a task here is where you're going
to build something this is what it has
to do and you have the materials and the
materials that are going to be used to
fabricate it and if they don't work you
can choose a different material aluminum
instead of iron etc etc and finally with
very few exceptions engineered artifacts
have a single function
and that means that you can design a
structure to actually maximize the
performance of that function also in
physics not in engineering but certainly
in engineering one accurate and precise
measurement measurement can actually
suffice
now biomechanics in biophysics well here
is where we get into a little bit of
trouble the environment is variable the
organism has to be examined and its
functions have to be inferred we have to
guess what something is doing yes a wing
a fin we can pretty much be sure that
our guess is correct but there are many
things like for example the prickles on
a rose these downward nasty-looking
things what are they really doing
are they grappling hooks or the
deterrence of herbivores are they doing
both the other thing is that an
organisms materials and structure are
the result of its evolutionary legacy it
didn't get there de novo it went through
a whole sequence of events and finally
at least in terms of biomechanics most
organic structures have multiple
functions not just single single ones so
you can't maximize the performance of
the function you actually have to
compromise and optimize and finally in
biophysics multiple measurements are
required
unlike physics I often tell my students
some of whom are here and none not sure
I've told them this if you measure an
electron accurately you know the mass of
an electron throughout the universe if
you measure a gerbil you happen to know
the weight of that gerbil on that day at
that time okay so we have many
challenges not the least of which is
that many biological models appear
overly simplistic because of the
multitude of functions that organisms
even a single cell has to perform I mean
the classic example there is assume a
spherical cow existing in a vacuum you
know this is what a lot of us sometimes
do imagine a spherical plant existing in
a vacuum well I can imagine it but I'm
going to find when I suppose the thing
is that things have certainly been
improved not improved improved and that
is our modeling techniques are a lot
more sophisticated with the rise of
computational sophistication computers
now can handle datasets that in my day
nobody would ever accumulate because
they knew they couldn't do a single
linear regression on it because in my
day you had to do it by hand the other
problem that we face is that models can
give the correct answers for the wrong
reason I'm giving you an example here of
Ptolemies astrolabe this little device
shown over here completely accurate
it could predict the motion of the
planets the known planets in those days
it could predict solar and lunar
eclipses with perfect fidelity to
reality there's only one little problem
it was a geocentric device it assumes
that the earth was in the center of the
solar system so he gave you the right
answers but from a mechanistic
understanding of the solar system was
totally wrong okay so with all of these
caveats in mind I'd like to give you a
few examples of the kind of modeling
that I did starting way back when when
most of you at least the young Lawrence
weren't even born I feel totally
antiquated the first one I want to talk
about is tissues in d-formation and
adrienne mentioned that my PhD involved
looking at least in part at this strange
little organism called protists
underneath and these are some s cm's and
yes SEMS were new when i was a graduate
student we were all very excited about
them and these are sem micrographs of
this fragments of this organism called
protists Affinia it's an upper Devonian
thing nobody really knows whether it's
an alga a liverwort or what but one of
the things that I was fascinated with
was it if you look here you can make out
cellular texture you can actually see
how those cells seems to seem to have
been aligned with each other and I've
blown it up here and those are little
black pencil marks looking at the arcs
of these different cells and I said to
myself self what can we do with these
data and the new technique that I became
aware of what's called finite element
analysis and finite element analysis is
where you make up essentially grids with
properties within each of these areas
that in my particular case where the
dimensions of these cells you spend many
nights with a microscope measuring the
size and the shape of these cells and
then you mesh things up and you create
based on the information that you have a
hypothetical apical meristem this by the
way is a finite element simulation of
what I thought the meristem looked like
and the beauty with finite elements is
that you can say grow make this thing
bigger construct what the organism might
have looked like and I just want to go
back one or a few slides and point out
that you'll notice there are things here
that are very different in shape
they're vile obe things and squashed
things things that look like Mickey
Mouse's ears until I came along those
were all described as separate species
proto salvinia Ravena proto Sylvania
arnoldii I produce salvinia FERC Ada and
I said well maybe my little computer
simulation will generate one of these
things and I'll be vindicated to get at
least part of a mini PhD well it turned
out that the computer simulations told
me this all of those fragments belong to
the same organism all of them could be
generated by manipulating the cell
divisions in the apical meristem and the
computer simulations actually gave me an
ontogeny for this fossil organism so how
do you validate this it's just pie in
the sky you actually go and look for the
intermediate stages that we're never
given a name a species name and MIT
because after macerating tons of
material I did manage to find
intermediates
and so my PhD committees sort of said
well yeah this is a computer simulation
it's not really paleobotany but okay
leave us as Adrian also mentioned I was
doing some organic geochemistry then I
was a dilettante I was just trying to
learn stuff and we had at the University
of Illinois a beautiful mass spec and so
we prepared specimens vaporized them did
all sorts of stuff and I managed to
isolate a number of compounds that are
thus far only known for land plants and
so it's likely even though this has
nothing to do with modeling it's likely
that protists have any lived on land
does that make it not an alga no but is
it not mutually exclusive there's
nothing in the definition of an alga
that says you can't live on land
it's just prejudice so we got I got
interested then Oh No
I see what the problem is the problem is
we have a loose connection and I'm it I
will not touch this computer again
except to start the show so I was
interested in yes
shaky hands because you might not know
it but I'm terribly nervous giving this
talk you're a very impressive group of
people so I started looking at issues
later on after I actually came to
Cornell thinking about finite element
analyses and how I could apply to living
plants and I was fascinated by hollow
things including my cranium but if if
you look if you look at a variety of
plants including a cuisine and you will
see that hollow stems are actually a
very common turns out from an
engineering point of view they're
perfect because if you bend or twist
something like a hollow stem if you look
at the distribution this is the maximum
these are always towards the outside and
the inside they're zero so there's no
reason to have stuff on the inside since
it's not providing any mechanical
support of any kind and if you eliminate
that by a mess you actually make the
material lighter and stronger and this
is why a lot of things like bicycles and
and frames of airplanes are made up of
hollow tubes well anyway what can we do
with hollow tubes well you can bend and
twist them and so I meshed up again I
love my finite element analysis and said
to myself what are the effects of these
nodal septa periodically the inter nodes
are separated by a nodal septa little
diaphragm of cells and also on many
grasses the base of the intra node is
classed by the base of the leaf the leaf
sheath and I wanted to know well what
are the contributions of these things
and so we twisted and we bent and we
looked at finite element simulations and
it turns out that the nodal septa
provide almost 25% of the mechanical
support of these structures they act as
struts
that actually absorb bending and
twisting energy they absorb the strain
energy and when the applied force is
removed they act like a spring they pop
back into place and we could actually
show this using real plants and
measuring with strain gauges the
importance of those diaphragms one of
the secretaries here many years ago Joan
Noah she liked and so it would get one
of her long knitting needles I get one
of these stems and I punch through all
of the nodal diaphragm measure the been
strength and the twisting strength and
we compared that to a nun surgically
manipulated grass or a cuisine of Stefan
22.5% of the strength of those
structures were the result of the nodal
diagram another 17% is actually provided
by the sheath that surrounds the base of
the internodes it acts like a girdle and
it is therefore in the proper place to
absorb most of the strain energy along
the internode we also then went into a
whole field of engineering called
cellular solids as botanists you're all
used to cellular solids if you think
about parenchyma it's a cellular solid
you have a liquid phase that's the
cytoplasm and you have a solid phase
those are the cell walls and it turns
out that cellular solids have a number
of properties biomechanical properties
that are influenced by the pressure of
the fluid inside of the cellular
components now in engineering
styrofoam's are an example of a cellular
solid in which the fluid phase is a gas
okay in botany the fluid phase is a
liquid cytoplasm so we did some
simulations and we predicted the effect
of the thickness and the radius of the
cell walls in these cellular solids and
we submitted these two tests and lo and
behold a computer model could be
validated within a 5 percent error so we
were getting pretty happy with this kind
of work which is still being pursued
in my lab by the way these are ongoing
biomechanical questions aerodynamics of
pollination so now I'm switching topics
it's another example going back to my
graduate days I was taught these things
these are some of the oldest known seed
plants well these aren't I mean these
are my watercolors these are
reconstructions of what the ovules look
like they're upper Devonian lower
Mississippian and they go by horrendous
names that I had to memorize like so
pingas Toma Hudson had sown Ensis he not
only had to memorize it you had to be
able to spell it not anymore
because nobody really cares well I was
taught when I was a graduate student
here you see a novel that looks pretty
much like a modern-day one there's a
micropyle there's the integrant but if
you look at some of these other little
critters and this is really a
megasporangium surrounded by what looks
like a dead squid and we were told as a
graduate student as graduate students
that this evolved from an ancestor that
looked like that and that the
coalescence of these squid like
tentacles in their fusion towards the
tip was a consequence of natural
selection operating on protection from
herbivores from little manipulated
terrestrial arthropods okay that would
go in there and eat the little eggs in
the little magnet commune fight and I
thought that was a very cute story
except I also know that these things
were wind pollinated or at least I was
told that they were in colony there
wasn't around in the Devonian upper
Mississippian but not the Devonian so I
said self um yeah this might be
protection but what about the influence
on pollen and so I built myself a wind
tunnel okay so there's the contraction
cone of the wind tunnel and the fan and
the regulator are all here and you might
wonder what that tube is this is the big
gadget that was really important um this
this was a but a bubble generator now
what do I mean by a bubble generator
it used a surfactant that to create
bubbles individual bubbles that were
filled with helium and you had a
centrifugal device over here that you
could actually select the size of the
bubbles that you wanted and the size of
the bubbles that I wanted were bubbles
that were neutrally buoyant in other
words the weight of the little soap
downward was counteracted by the lifting
force of the helium so you could
actually see a bubble hover in
motionless air and not move so then you
shine a big bright light on them okay
and what you're seeing now are these
little bubbles moving around a cylinder
you're looking down on the cylinder you
see the leeward sound side and you see
the turbulence that generally is
generated on the downwind side so now we
had a way of visualizing airflow
patterns and we needed to photograph
them and we needed to know what they
were doing from the top and the bottom
to get a construct for three-dimensional
airflow patterns around these structures
and here are some of the pictures
pictures I built little scale models
using clay and there you see in each
case the airflow is coming from the left
to the right and you see an impact
shion's own any music particles which is
hitting the surface but notice there was
a stagnant area where turbulence was
being generated so he got a little bit
excited about this and we did a long
many series of simulations and we looked
at the airflow patterns that
statistically most dominant airflow
especially around the receptive parts of
these structures to see whether or not
there was a bias that might carry pollen
towards the micropyle or the micropyle
like structure then we got really fancy
and we made what we called pseudo pollen
we could construct little things that
were like pollen only they were bigger
so he could see them and we coated the
surface with sticky stuff and then we
put them in a wind tunnel and we would
see happily would they come near the
micropyle well this was interesting but
it was not all that exciting because it
was
not conclusive so then I built small
little models and used like a podium
spores to see what would happen and what
we found was that the structure that
looks more most like modern-day ovules
actually was the most efficient at
capturing pollen around the micro polar
lip and this was just a statistical
study in which we looked at the maximum
pollen that were actually towards the
micropyle critical wind speeds and we
found that the structures that look like
modern-day ovules were the most
efficient at the lowest wind speeds so
this was kind of nice and at least it
suggested that maybe the evolution of
the integument might have been under two
pressures from natural selection one is
protection and one is for capturing wind
pollen well I got excited about this and
I thought well why do I have to work
with dead things
I can work with living things there are
a lot of wind pollinated things like
pine and grasses not all grasses are
wind pollinated I think there's one that
grows in the tropics described by baauer
that's actually insect pollinated can't
remember the name but they see Jerry
Davis going like this rather than that's
so apparently I'm okay so we started
working with pinecones and we got a
little photography got a little bit
better that we could actually look at
very small scale of turbulence patterns
and what we found here was that there
were three things that a populate
pinecone does one is it produces
cyclonic vortices that wrap around the
ortho stickies and porosity keys of the
scale of you Liveris brac complexes
there were also little doldrums between
the axis of the cone and each of these
reproductive entities and then there was
back slip kind of turbulence and flow so
we got excited about this and we pursued
it and the next big invention was a
stroboscope stroboscopic light lighting
so now we broke those streamlines into
fragments and you see that successive
images of my bubbles
okay what's nice about this is since I
know the rate at which the light is
flashing I can measure the rate of
movement okay so now I could not just
look at patterns of airflow I could look
at distributions of local velocities
which from an aerodynamic point of view
is much more impressive now I just want
to point out what that when you're
dealing with fluid mechanics you have
two ways in which you can analyze it
when it's coiled and the oil Irian
approach and the other is called the
Lagrangian approach what's an oily Rhian
approach it's as if you were scaring out
a window and looking at everything that
came by that little piece of space okay
that's the oil Irian approach the other
is Lagrangian and that is you actually
follow what a particle is doing along
its trajectory and we had to do both to
really get an understanding of what was
going on oh this is the oil Irian
diagnosis of an ovulate cone this
velocity in meters per second and so you
just look at a little bit of space and
you look at all the pollen grains or all
the bubbles that are passing through
that space and you begin to quantify
what its material what it's a fluid
mechanical behavior is and what we found
was yes there was inertial impaction in
other words pollen grains would just hit
the cone but what was happening is that
the airflow patterns created by the
ovulate cone itself biased the
sedimentation of the pollen grains on
the upper surface of the ovulate bracht
complexes so this was actually a very
sophisticated device in the sense it's a
turbine but it's not rotating around its
axis it's causing the air to rotate
around its axis and it's biasing the
distribution of those air flow patterns
to get pollen towards where the ovules
are which are in the ad axial surface of
the black complex
well we didn't want to just use models
so this is a real oops this is a real
pinecone this is real pine pollen these
are photographs of the worst of our
experiments because you know there's
just a cloud here you might see little
dots but nothing conclusive so we refine
the technique
refine the technique using stroboscopic
lighting and just to blow this little
piece up here these now are the
successive locations of a single pollen
drink you digitize this you computerized
this stuff and again you crank out the
numbers and you get the Lagrangian
approach so we're looking at individual
pollen grains moving around a real
ovulate cone what we found out was
rather surprising because when you
actually look at the number of pollen
grains that are hitting the ovules of
different species of pine okay so here
are the ovulate cones here are the
pollen grains from those ovulate cones
and what you see is the pollen that is
most successful comes from the species
of the cone to which it belongs so there
is selective filtration lotta noise a
lot of randomness but wind pollination
in this case is not random it has a very
deterministic component okay then we got
into computer simulations real computer
simulations these are artificial pollen
grains we were looking at what are the
dimensions and densities of pollen that
are the optimal for different kinds of
plants this is ephedra these are the
ovules of the fedra those are the little
pollination droplets we had a lot of fun
I don't have time to get into all of
these stories but I can lend you
reprints grasses okay we did the same
thing with grasses using real pollen
from the
and we digitized them and we looked at
the aerodynamics around them and what we
found we were looking here at - let me
just go back we're looking at two
different species one is site area
Janicki alotta shown here it has a very
compact panicle okay the florets flowers
are are very close together something
like a pinecone in overall appearance we
also looked at this this is a gracias
high mollis which has a very loose
panicle you see little clusters of
flowers but on their individual stems
and the fluid mechanics around these two
dense panicle loose panicle very very
different okay as you might expect but
the other thing is we noticed that the
loose panicle was a natural harmonic
oscillator each of these little clusters
of flowers on the stems of different
lengths different stiffness they were
oscillating in different directions and
at different speeds whereas the satalia
Kanaka was oscillating in a very
predictable natural harmonic we could
actually measure the harmonic frequency
of these things using a biaxial trend
optical transducer that could actually
track the motion of this thing in all
directions and then you could put it
through a Fournier analysis and you
would get the natural harmonic the
second harmonic the third harmonic and
it turns out let me go back turns out
that you could actually not only talk
about the aerodynamics but we now could
talk about the material properties of
the stem because the natural frequency
is related to the stiffness of the
material to young's modulus and this
goddess interested in solid mechanics
and the interface between solid and
fluid mechanics again i'm just giving
these as samples i don't have time to go
into all the detail besides which
they're excruciatingly ly boring and
they're published okay so what else do
you do well again it's Adrienne
and I was undergraduate in major in
mathematics I was always fascinated by
the symmetry of plants I mean you look
at a plant and you just say it's
beautiful but it's beautiful because in
part of its symmetry and so I got
interested in fellow taxi the
arrangements of believes and just to
give you a few examples distich --is
example in libya opposite dicus aid in
some kind of MIT spiral arrangement etc
there all these beautiful symmetries
that seem to conform to what is called a
Fibonacci series helios d Bonacci the
son of Bonacci named contracted to
fibonacci okay but it's fili estheban
aki anyway
what he did is you know he created these
wonderful mathematical kind of series
you add up the numbers and you get the
next number then you add up the previous
number to that number and you get the
next number the next number the next
number and you can start with any number
but you just use this a mathematical
series and if you make fractions of them
like here and you keep increasing the
numbers they converge on the golden mean
you can convert these fractions into
angles and so the series will always
approach expressed in in angles 137.5 or
there abouts okay and this excited
mathematicians in botanist for hundreds
of years basically because the Golden
Rule now that plants have learned the
Golden Rule this is why they arrange
their leaves the way they do well it's
not true okay and a long time ago we
created a little mathematical model for
the arrangements of leaves on a single
stem and you need only a few parameters
you need the deflection angle of the
leaf you need the rotation angle of the
leaf you need the distance between
successive leaves
you need the divergence angle that's
Fibonacci series and then you can play
around with the leaf the length of the
petiole the width and the length of the
petiole we kept things simple all leaves
are of you are either ellipses or
circles no lo being nothing just to see
what would happen and you can create all
of these different pillow tactic
patterns here now you're looking down on
a kind of rosette can put these
mathematically into a computer and say
okay the Sun is going overhead from dawn
to dusk how much energy do these leaves
collectively absorb what is their
efficiency at trapping light and now you
have Morpho spaces what is some MorphOS
space well in this case we have the
Fibonacci angle the divergence angle
here we have the amount of energy a
plant can absorb and by the way this is
the angle and that's the actual fraction
so they're really the same axes and
wherever you see this big broad line
here that's the golden mean 130 7.5 and
you can see 4 little stubby rosettes or
rosettes with what looked like pizza
kind of shovels or 4 round leaves that
really the optimal is the Fibonacci
convergent series 130 7.5 but the minute
you start playing with internodal
distances for example or our patio
lengths things of that sort the
difference between all of these fibbin
of all of these divergence angles of
leaf arrangement are washed out the one
is no better than the other ok so the
only time that the golden mean seems to
work is if you're a cabbage if you're a
rosette where all the leaves are
basically shading each other
the minute you start elongating or
changing the geometry of the patio or
change the deflection angles of those
leaves it doesn't matter how you arrange
it which is really good for clivia
because the leaves are in two different
rows and it doesn't seem to bother it we
also could simulate the effect of
latitude and things of that sort and if
you play with loud
all of those leaf arrangements can be
equally efficient it really doesn't
matter okay I got two more to go and I'm
gonna go through it I hope in time but
this is okay so early land plant
evolution well when I was taught
paleo botany we were all excited about
the Devonian because that's when
everything seemed to happen okay my
professors were excited I was excited
but when you look at the plants from the
Devonian they're actually excruciatingly
lis boring right I mean really a few
where taxonomy today you might classify
all of these things into one family or
one something or another and just give
them different generic and species names
binomials but the beauty of these plants
is that they're botanical tuning forks I
can mathematically describe their
geometry with only a few variables okay
I need to know again the bifurcation
angle what is the angle between
bifurcations what is the rotation angle
and what is the probability of branching
other things that I can include our
diameter and length of these elements
and I can create a universe of all
mathematically possible structures in a
fairly simple Cartesian coordinate
system this is a simple morphic space
you can go n dimensional you don't have
to be three-dimensional right I mean
they card there's that little thing you
have X Y Z you know it's coordinates can
I add other dimensions in other words
other parameters to describe the
morphology well of course I can I can
add more axes and forget about being
three-dimensional
the other way to deal with this almost
an infinite number of axes is you line
them up like this and this point in that
point in that point at that point in
this point in that point are all the
same points one point that's an object
in n-dimensional space so don't let
anybody tell you that you can't plot
more than three dimensions you can't
it's easy okay
computers can handle this I can't okay
there is slices through the Morpho space
that just took three slices so you get
things like siloed um you get things
that look like real trees you get things
that yeah sort of look like conifers and
then you get to things that look like a
mess okay and years ago I gave this talk
in New Zealand and I said well there's
nothing really like that and they all
started laughing and they said you
haven't seen our dive arrogating shrubs
have you and I said no and they said
well there are stems that grow inward
not outward and I said well that's them
over there so you know so okay so now I
have this more foot space what am I
going to do with it well it turns out
that I can quantify the performance of
those morphologies in the Morpho space
okay I can actually calculate their
ability to intercept light to conduct
fluids to reproduce and to provide
mechanical support I've written books
about how to do this okay so I this is
my gross self advertisement and I can
give you free copies nobody buys them
anyway I could have made a fortune with
this it is the best cure for insomnia
that I know of I can't even read more
than three pages and none stay awake
so yeah just to give you a nice oh you
move the Sun over something like this
and you calculated self-shading etc you
can look at mechanical stability what
are the moment arms the influence of
gravity I can look at the probability of
discharging spores in the distance those
sports travel etcetera etc so now now I
can quantify the performance of each of
those objects in the Morpho space and
what i can do is i could simulate an
adaptive walk okay I can start someplace
here
maybe the earliest known vascular land
plant and I can look around in that
Morpho space next to it and say is there
anything that's just as good or better
and so the computer finds that
morphology and it keeps doing this until
it gets to a morphology that is
surrounded by nothing that's better or
as good okay
it's an adaptive peek we had to test it
we had to know does this really work so
it turns out that this is salla cornea
Europa it's a little hallow fight it
looks like one of these boring Devonian
plants but it's actually an angiosperm
but it had a trifurcation kind of
branching pattern and what we found was
the geometry of this plant changes
dramatically depending upon the density
of plants how closely they grow so we
simulated densities effect on the
ability to intercept light okay and we
compared the morphology of the plants at
different plant densities to the
morphology that the computer predicted
and lo and behold we were right
computers are wonderful things until
they failure so we said okay let's look
at the Devonian plants for different
functions and the first thing we tested
is light interception and mechanical
stability can you do them simultaneously
what happens okay there's a conflict by
the way because if you want to be
mechanically stable you want to be
vertical if you want to maximize light
interception you want to lie on your
side so they're the opposite of each
other you have to optimize not maximize
and so we started with Kooks
this is the earliest known vascular
plant fossil we found its location in
the Morpho space that's what the
computer says cooksonia looks like and
now we go through the adaptive walk and
we ended with that so just to very
quickly show you what was happening is
that the computer was predicting with
successive events to go from something
like a rainy out like plant with equal
branching to unequal branching to
overtopping to then lateral branches
that started to play mate and that
looked something like this and what was
really curious is that that's exactly
what the t loam theory predicts by
zimmerman this is how you get mega tilts
okay at least that's what he thought
well the computer said yeah dr.
Zimmerman you seem to be right the only
problem with something like this it's an
opaque model it may not be right it's
just telling you what the basis is of
your assumptions so by the way only two
functions right mechanics and light what
happens if you just want to maximize
each performance what happens if you put
these in pairs or triplets or what
happens when you say do them all okay so
when I'm not going to show you walks I'm
going to show you the end result this is
what happens when you have single
functions maximizing reproduction
conservation of surface area maximizing
mechanical stability light interception
now what happens when you do two
functions I won't read off all of these
but you'll notice things are looking a
little bit more complicated what happens
if you have three functions things are
getting much more complicated what if
you do all four those are all equal in
their performance
so many ways to make everything work
kind of fun because what it's saying is
if I'm a single function like a machine
I can maximize the performance my
fitness but if I keep adding functions
the number of tests entries so did the
number of equally efficient phenotypes
but their global fitness is down this
kind of explains why when you dive into
the desert all the desert plants don't
look the same okay not all trees look
the same they're equally good a long
time to talk about this but imagine if
you're an engineer and I say design a
toaster I'm gonna be really good now how
about a toaster and a hairdryer okay
so I'm not gonna go on to this I'm going
to end with this so that you can all
have lunch last thing I want to talk
about is forest dynamics so real for
it's very complicated but it turns out
that if you go into the data and you
start looking at trends within sizes and
girths of trees in a variety of
different force you find very strict
allometric relationships this one is the
log of standing leaf mass versus the log
of standing stem mass and you can see
that's a log log linear regression over
many orders of magnitude from forests as
different as conifers and mixed
deciduous forests so there are rules
somehow question is what are they so
Shawn Hammond of one of my graduate
students many years ago had a knack for
computer simulations and I said Shawn
how about modeling forests and he looked
at me and he said we'll be that get me a
PhD and I said yes so so he said ok so
we started looking at rules and one of
them was given to us by this gentleman
many hundreds of years ago
this is Apollonius of Tyana I remember I
remember his theorems from when I took
geometry complex geometry yes well he
was he was a little younger then but he
was interested in how do you package
things together for example how many
circles can I get into this kind of
geometry notice this is the arc of a
circle that's the arc of a circle that's
the arc of a circle and so he had some
mathematics that we began to play with
and we started introducing those rules
into the computer simulations but
another problem that we had was how much
do I give to make new leaves to make new
roots and new stems this is a banking
problem you get so much energy in a year
and you have to produce leaves you have
to produce stems you have to produce
roots and if you produce too many leaves
with respect to the stem you can fall
over if I produce too few roots with
respect to stems I can fall over so this
is the classic allocation of biomass not
money and we had a beautiful algorithm
starting with a little seedling energy
for growth reproductively mature yes no
energy for reproduction violate a
physical law no two objects can occupy
the same space you die okay so okay so
here at the beginning of our simulations
and we were going low density and then
watching them grow higher density higher
density higher density and now for all
of this trauma I want to show you a
movie but first of all I need my classes
because I have to press a button and I
can't find it not to worry
there we go okay so what you're looking
at now is a single propagule that is
reproducing you're looking at it from
this side and looking down we see that's
a single seed and every iteration was
one year okay so now that was one
propagule I want to show you what you
what happens when you randomly scatter
those seeds
and this is going to go for over 600
years those little specs you see those
are the seats that are being released
from the canopy later on you'll see some
light gaps where an old tree dies and
then you see some little puppies filling
in see that oh this is so cute you know
you can watch it on Sunday when you're
bored and it's snowing
that's almost every Sunday but how do
you test a model like this no am i doing
why isn't it going oh wait now these
darn computers I don't understand why
they don't do what I tell them to do
well let's see if we can do it this way
okay so how do you test a model what we
looked around for forestry data and it
was wonderful to find this publication
from published in Italian University of
Forenza Italy imagine they went out into
a new forest and measured properties for
80 years how many leaves
what's the girth of the stems what's the
height of the trees over 80 years the
school of Forestry just had new people
come in PhD students you might go out
there measure the force so we had data
and what we could do is we could
parameterize our computer model for this
tree a bees album okay and now what I'm
going to show you our graphs that look
like this one of these symbols is the
data and the other symbol is the
prediction of the computer model
nice nice but there's something else
that came out that we never expected the
computer model predicted how old the
trees were before they would produce
seed and that's what we found in the
data set we had cross-validation in
other words we had an emergent property
that we never put into the program and
the program made a prediction that we
didn't expect what happened to be true
so what have I learned from 45 years of
modeling it's fun but I going to propose
a few tools and then I'll be done
how do you evaluate well you fit
empirical data I just showed you and you
use the technique called
cross-validation you look for
predictions that aren't in the algorithm
that still comply with reality okay like
we did with the ABS defining a model
scope it's really important to know when
a model is in applicable what are the
range of phenomena they handle you can
interpolate but the danger is to
extrapolate you can't go beyond the
boundaries of your model unless you have
data unless you have data to test it and
last but not least the appearance of
emergent properties the appearance of
maturation that that last model
predicted okay
the fallacy of causality is always their
correlation strong positive correlations
do not necessarily prove that you have
cause and effect that's always a
temptation but you have to resist it so
[Applause]
questions
Peter so two factors a your leaves are
not really ok can you mention that were
you able to look at what would happen
when light exceeds what belief means
so therefore
but you got actually more efficient for
the community which which illustrates
what's happened to corn they not the
yields like crazy by changing the leaf
angles washing in many more plants
burrito no the both at both both of
those questions are really good so to
answer the first one yes we can one of
the parameters would be the opacity of
the leaf the transmission of
photosynthetically useful radiation
because of course a lot of the light
coming out of it is green and that's not
particularly exciting yeah that to the
question of leaf orientation when it
comes to the canopies of trees the best
assumption is that the leaf orientation
is random because I have a leaf like
this I have a leaf like this I have a
leaf like this and if you have more than
a few leaves you can basically say you
can either model it as a frequency
distribution or you can just say it's
all roundup okay and it turns out that
it doesn't really matter once you get to
a certain size because you have so many
lives right it doesn't have much effect
yep we looked at the phenomena like that
and latitude now I never worked on corn
it's way too boring no offense
what we find
thank you very much
both questions do biology hosta model it
depends on your discipline I mean if I
was into metabolomic side be looking at
metabolic systems if I was into genetics
and development it would be gene
regulatory networks if I was into
ecology it would be community dynamics
all of those are amenable to modeling
okay so the model is a tool and the
important thing about a tool is you have
to have an important question it's the
question that drives the choice of tool
not the tool that drives the selection
of the question I'm kind of old school
Brandi
well
and what I think that with Shawn
Hammonds computer modeling we saw so
many emergent properties not just the
onset of reproductivity and maturation
but a lot of other phenomena that we
never expected a simple model to produce
okay like density dependent depth okay
which can be used to model the spread of
pathogens so yeah there are a lot of
applications not just to forested
communities so you've got the model of
the forest community and then you also
have the model of the forms of the plant
so two questions from one cannot be
combined together so that you could
actually model the forest community not
just looking like
plant but looking like multiple species
and how those giving
can I answer that question for so if you
haven't heard the question is can you
use this kind of model not to look at
mono specific stands but what happens
when you have different species
interacting and in fact we did that we
actually parameterised a number of
different kinds of trees because we were
looking at we were interested in
competitive exclusion to one of these
things muscled out the other in very few
cases we found that coexistence was the
rule what would happen however if you
started with equal numbers of seeds that
were randomly distributed you would see
that some species would be repressed so
their numbers would drop below 25% if
you had four but then they would plateau
and they would persist for as long as we
ran the simulations and that's something
that Shawn is actually following up on
now that he's got a tenure-track
position so you had another question
if you use sort of the history instead
of people to their potential forms that
could be there they're restricted in
their history and their branching
pattern and what they look like
can you use it
yes you can't said the question is can
you use the two last models that I
talked about where you had different
forms can use them to fertilize
fertilize one to another you can okay
but when you start modeling something
like that you have to make a large
number of assumptions and the results
will be very dependent something again
the early evolution land plant model is
an opaque model okay it may not tell us
anything about reality but what it does
do is it makes the logical consequences
of our assumptions transparent I will
tell you that those simulations were
done on Atari simulators Atari computers
we had four Atari computers hooked up as
a network and some of those simulations
took months and this took a lot of
brownej you would lose the results of
those simulations so it was not easy now
we've got big computers okay what took
us months maybe take a few hours I mean
those the polling that I did with finite
elements with protists of India that was
using Fortran Fortran you know stacks
and stacks of what looked like postcards
the little holes punch you drop and
we're scarred all over again is that it
thank you for coming have a lovely day
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu